ويعقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه مغلقه مساء
اليوم الاثنين
يتلقى خلالها اعضاء المجلس احاطه من وكيل
الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه
بشان الاستجابه للزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا وسيشارك مندوبات تركيا وسوريا لدى
الامم المتحده في الجلسه المغلقه وستليها
جلسه مشاورات مغلقه اخرى يناقش خلالها بل
يناقش خلالها فقط المجلس يناقش التطورات
وكيفيه الاستجابه وتاتي الجلسه في ظل
تعبير الامين العام للامم المتحده عن امله
في ان يتم السماح للامم المتحده باستعمال
معبر حضوري اخر بالاضافه الى معبر باب
الهوى لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
سوريا
في غضون ذلك قالت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى
الامم المتحده ليندا توماس جريند في بيان
ان الولايات المتحده تدعو مجلس الامن
الدولي الى التصويت الفوري على السماح
بارسال مساعدات دوليه الى شمال غربي سوريا
الخاضعه لسيطره المعارضه عبر مزيد من
المعابر الحدوديه من تركيا وقالت جرين
فيلد ان كل ساعه لها اهميتها في الوقت
الحالي وان الناس في المناطق المتضرره
بشمال غربي سوريا يعتمدون على المجتمع
الدولي وفق تعبيرها
من جهه اخرى نقلت وكاله روتوز عن متحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض
ويجب السماح بدخول جميع المساعدات
الانسانيه الى شمال غربي سوريا عبر جميع
الحدود والمعابر واضاف المتحدث انه يتعين
توزيع المساعدات على جميع المناطق
المتضرره دون تاخير على حد قوله